as democrats remain divided in congress
it seems their supporters are flushing
civility down the drain as arizona
senator kirsten cinema found out she
can't even use the bathroom without
being harassed by these radicals
but this lack of
right now
we need solutions to build that better
plan we knocked on doors for you to get
you elected and just how we got you
elected we can get you out of office if
you don't support what you promised us
this lack of civility is nothing new
from the left just ask larry elder who
is attacked by an egg throwing nut job
while campaigning to be california's
next governor but don't worry joe biden
says it's all part of the process
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to
people who have secret service stand
around them
um so it's it's part of the process
here to react former california
gubernatorial candidate and radio host
larry elder larry what do you have to
say to the president's response to this
situation
well imagine if a guerrilla mask wearing
woman threw an egg at say kamala harris
or barack obama they'd be calling it a
hate crime there'd be an international
manhunt to find her this is the kind of
lack of civility that goes on this
recall effort
polls showed ben at some point that the
effort might very well succeed and then
they brought in the heavy lumber they
outspent me 10 to 1 200 million dollars
and 20 million dollars barack obama cut
an ad for him they asked
snoop dogg to tweet out his 19 million
followers this was a republican takeover
led by quote uh the black face of white
supremacy close quote that would be me
never mind the issues that we that we
campaigned on the rising crime rising
homelessness uh the way he shut down
small businesses to the point where a
third of all of small businesses are now
gone forever many of which were run by
ethnic minorities the fact that uh in
school learning for the eighty percent
of the public school students were black
and brown was denied before the pandemic
then seventy five percent of black boys
could not read at state levels of
proficiency math scores even worse half
of all third graders could not again
math scores are even worse i support
choice in in public education gavin
newsom my opponent does not and by the
way barack obama k-12 enjoyed a personal
private education as did his uh his
daughters but they opposed choice for
black and brown parents when the polls
show they want that and then they're hot
the rise of the cost of living in
california eight hundred thousand
dollars average price of a home in
california been that's 150 percent above
the national average it is the primary
reason why the percentage of blacks and
browns living in san francisco and in
l.a over the last 20 or 30 years has
declined because they cannot afford the
price of a home and i'm the black face
of white supremacy it's it's nuts look
it's it is nuts but one aspect of this
i'd like to hear you address directly is
you know we see this action from the
left constantly that they'll get in your
face they'll yell at you when you're out
uh eating they will they will you know
invoke all of these different
aspects of aggressive politicking and
set civility aside they never get
criticized by the media for that they're
just they can run pell mel over any kind
of expectations in this case against a
female senator just trying to go to the
bathroom and there never seems to be any
backlash never any criticism that says
maybe you shouldn't do that
well ben that one's easy that's because
the media are complicit for example i've
never asked anybody to vote for me or
against me because i'm black let alone
that i would have become the first black
governor of california but there was a
long negative article about me in the
new york times never mentioning that i'm
black let alone that if i got elected i
would have been the first black governor
of california but in the very same issue
of the new york times that same day big
long article about quote the first
female governor close quote of new york
so it was relevant that she had a d at
the end of her name she was first i have
an r at the end of my name and i cease
being black as far as the new york times
is concerned
you know that really does seem to be the
thing the thing about this larry is it's
so obvious they don't hide it anymore
it's all right out there in the opening
all you have to do is pay attention to
what they say take them at their word
and you can see the game being played in
front of you just 30 seconds what can
people do within their own communities
to push back against this kind of of
rising incivility on the left
fight back tell the truth about rising
crime who it affects tell the truth
about rising homelessness who
homelessness who's who it affects 6.5 of
californians are black 40 of the
homeless or black and and gavin newsom
has done nothing about the homeless
population except make the problem worse
worse tell the truth and sooner or later
the left is going to hit rock bottom and
they're going to have to rethink their
assumptions and overturn this one-party
rule we have in california and the super
majority of democrats in the in
sacramento legislature hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else